donc il s'appelle with the boss c'est
joey starr et son collectif sur dvd
alors il ya un documentaire un l'avant
le ton truc là mais c'est un peu en
retrait le très sexy mais c'est le
teaser voici le teaser mais moi le
teaser en fait j'ai des vues après avoir
vu donc forcément ça va on parle un peu
plus et puis
protagonistes donc ça vachement plus
c'est en fait nous en son système son
système c'est d'espoir et itinérante
qu'on fait à plusieurs dj ont nagé avec
moi collectif de dj plus un collectif de
rappeurs donc c'est entre autres nous en
son système nous en studio chez nous
dans la cave nous sur ce show de radio
qui a lieu deux fois par semaine tout en
sachant par exemple le samedi on fait
des pics où on est premiers nationale ça
paraît bizarre mais c'est vrai mais ça
nous surprend et enfin tu tousses
poursuit autour quoi je pense qu'on est
un d'écrou de hip hop parisiens les plus
actifs en faire la première est ce qu'on
est
je tenais ce plaisir parce qu'on n'est
pas ce qu'on parce qu'on est un peu on
fait du live on fait de la prod on est
en toi éditeur de montrer qu'on est
voilées qu'on essaye de contrôler la
machine au possible quoi notre notre but
il ya 15 ans c'était de n'avoir que ça à
faire aujourd'hui on y est et puis c'est
ce qu'on voulait montrer quoi voilà on
est déjà ça
un wti à joey starr bull par quatorze
personnalités arrière kool shen il ya
eric et ramzy à edouard baer ya béatrice
dalle qui dit des choses formidables sur
vous et c'est vrai que béatrice dalle
elle vous a découvert bien avant les
autres parce qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde se rend compte que qui nous est
la fée ya longtemps béatrice et de mieux
voir pourtant joué dans des kermesses
couet
elle était là encore après puis je pense
que c'est pas que seulement moins qu'à
regarder je pense qu arraché à capter
l'énergie qui a vu sur le truc ça lui
plaisait quoi comme elle dit on était
plus rock et rock and roll que les
autres donc je pense que c'est ce qui
lui a parlé c'est vrai qu'il appelle
jean claude
jeu pour l'égalité des sexes la parité
c'est ça chez moi